Apparently, Sony's Morbius will be a very
specific kind of vampire — the sexy kind.
"Very dashing."
Actor Jared Leto shared what appears to be
a set photo from the forthcoming flick to
his Instagram recently, and if you can look
past the rippling torso and tight abs, you
may find there's more going on than meets
the eye.
The actor has been all about teasing Morbius
via social media: On April 4th, 2019, he even
posted a short video of himself in character,
standing on a busy city street while throngs
of passersby rush around him in a blur.
Leto claimed to have posted the set photo
in honor of the anniversary of This is War,
the third album by his rock band 30 Seconds
to Mars.
But it's obviously meant to be a bit of a
Morbius tease as well…
See that dark smear of blood at the corner
of Leto's mouth?
So, to state the obvious: Jared Leto is a
good-looking man, and he's obviously following
in the time-honored tradition of superhero
movie stars like Thor's Chris Hemsworth by
getting into incredible shape for his role
as Dr. Michael Morbius, the biochemist who
has traditionally been the staunch opponent
of your friendly neighborhood Spider-Man.
But there are a couple of possible clues in
the photo that warrant a closer look.
First, Leto is sporting a distinctive Casio
digital wristwatch... the kind that was popular
in the eighties and nineties.
This could be a clue about the time period
Morbius will be set in.
So far, director Daniel Espinosa hasn't revealed
any real plot details or the film's period
setting, but the watch's placement here certainly
invites speculation.
Of course, it could just be indicative of
Leto's taste in timepieces.
Difficult to say.
More importantly: Either Leto has suddenly
sprouted a whole bunch of moles on his face,
or he's covered in those tracking dots used
in motion-capture performances.
Note that in his vampire form, Morbius is,
well… frankly, he's hideous in the comics.
Rather than practical makeup, it appears that
special effects house Nvizage will be using
CGI to create the Living Vampire's ghastly
look.
And yes, that's the same house that provided
the effects for Sony's Venom.
"We are Venom."
This could be viewed as a positive or a negative,
depending on how you feel about Venom's special
effects.
While plenty of fans were perfectly satisfied
with the title character's appearance, others
felt that the CGI left a lot to be desired.
Some moviegoers even thought the effects looked
dated.
Of course, Venom and Morbius are two characters
with completely different looks, and even
if Nvizage fell short in rendering the former,
they could still totally crush it when it
comes to Morbius.
After all, the special effects house did awesome
work for Espinosa on his film Life and on
last year's underrated Nazi zombie thriller
Overlord.
Plus, it's worth noting that Venom made 855
million dollars worldwide, which may encourage
Sony to pony up a bit more cash for Morbius'
special effects budget.
At any rate, Leto's excitement over the upcoming
film is positively contagious, and we're psyched
to see what spin he puts on the material.
Following Venom, Morbius will be the second
installment in the Sony Universe of Marvel
Characters, which the studio is building because
it still holds the rights to a whole bunch
of characters associated with Spider-Man.
The Sony and Marvel deal won't last forever,
and Sony's leverage with Marvel could depend
on how well its Sony Universe of Marvel offerings
do at the box office.
As previously noted, Venom did just fine.
We'll see just how big of a bargaining chip
Morbius represents when it hits the big screen
on July 31st, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here.
Plus, even more exclusive Looper videos about
Morbius, Spiderman, and the Sony Universe
of Marvel Characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.